[Music]
i should also probably mention that
my name's not technically sean
what
what is it
it's
shanghi
yeah
you changed your name from shang to sean
yeah i don't i wonder i wonder how your
father found you i was 15 years old
right what is what is your name change
logic you going into hiding and your
name is michael you want to change it to
michelle that's that's not what happened
it's like hi my name is gina i'm going
to go into hiding my new name is gina
yeah okay oh yeah you can hear me
[Music]
throughout my life
the ten rings gave our family power
if you wanted them to be yours one day
you have to show me you are strong
enough to carry them
i
you are a product of all who came before
you
the legacy of your family
you are your mother
and whether you like it or not
you are also your father
i told my men
they wouldn't be able to kill you if
they tried
glad i was right
he was just a criminal
who murders people
start a new life
but i could never
escape his shadow
my son
you can't run from your past
is this what you wanted
[Music]
you got this
thank you
[Music]
you